[موسيقى]
هذا موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قالت وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه ان الفلسطينيه استشهد
متاثرا بجروح اصيب بها برصاص الاحتلال
خلال اقتحام مخيم عقبه جبر بمدينه اريحا
ظهر امس
قالت مقرره الامم المتحده الخاصه بحقوق
الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه انها ستحقق
في واقعه استخدام قوته الاحتلال لدروع
بشريه خلال اقتحامها مخيم عقبه جبر
وصف للمتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
تصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي الداعيه
لمحو قريه حوار الفلسطينيه بغير المسؤوله
والمقززه على حد قوله ودع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي لادانتها
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه في تقرير اطلعت عليه الجزيره ان
نتائج تحليل عينات في منشاه فوردو اظهرت
وجود جزيئات يورانيوم عالي التخصيب بنسبه
83.7 وهي النسبه اللازمه لصنع قنبله نوويه
وقالت المندوبه الامريكيه بالامم المتحده
ان ايران زادت تخصيب اليورانيوم منذ
انسحاب واشنطن من الاتفاق النووي وجددت
التاكيد على ان بلادها لن تسمح بحصول
طهران على سلاح نووي
في المقابل يتهم وزير الخارجيه الايراني
واشنطن بانها غير قادره على اتخاذ قرار
شجاع بالعوده للاتفاق
اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان القوات الروسيه احبطت محاوله هجوم
اوكرانيه مكثفه بطائرات مسيره على منشات
في شبه جزيره القرن
هذا وتحتدم المعارك في جبهه بخموتا
الاستراتيجيه بين القوات الاوكرانيه
وميليشيا فاجنر شرقيه اوكرانيا وقالت
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه انها متمسكه
لاستعاده السيطره على المدينه وانها قامت
بارسال وحدات عسكريه اضافيه للدفاع عن
موقع ريبار العسكريه التابع لروسيا ان
ميليشيا فاجنر تقدمت في الجهه الشماليه
الغربيه لمدينه باتجاه اخر طرق امدادات
الجيش الاوكراني في المدينه
قال وزير العد الامريكيين بلاده تحقق في
كيفيه دخول اجزاء امريكيه المصدر في بعض
المسيرات والصواريخ التي سقطت في اوكرانيا
مررت لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي مشروع قرار يسمح للرئيس الامريكي
بحظر تيك توك الصيني وتطبيقات اخرى مملوكه
لدول اجنبيه في الولايات المتحده
فلا مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
الامريكيه
في اصل جائحه كورونا وتوصل الى انه كان
على الارجح حادثا معمليا في مدينه وهران
الصينيه
في المقابل شككت الخارجيه الصينيه في
مصداقيه الاستنتاجات الامريكيه ووصفتها
بانها تلاعب سياسي
الى اللقاء